in our eyes Charlie could perform
miracles Charlie was a God Manson's lost
girls Patricia KRENWINKEL Leslie Van
Houten and Susan Atkins each are serving
life sentences for murder
Atkins is played by Eden Brolin Josh's
daughter and James's granddaughter Susan
Atkins is just such a character and
she's wonderful and beautiful and ugly
and and loyal and I just wanted to play
her I was excited to get into her shoes
Atkins took part and all eight Manson
family murders including actress Sharon
Tate
she died in prison in 2009 it's not that
bad a couple days and you'll be back to
normal
Greer grammer daughter of Kelsey plays
homecoming queen turned murderer van
Houten and van houten is still in prison
for killing Leno and rosemary LaBianca
there's definitely a good amount of drug
use you see us smoking a lot drugs is a
very big part of who these people were
and so it's a very big part of the movie
Christian Matson is the son of the
hateful eight Michael Madsen and his
aunt is Joyce Virginia Madsen all these
people are looking for acceptance and
looking for guidance he plays Tex Watson
convicted of seven Manson killings and
Jeff Ward plays Manson the evil
mastermind both are still serving life
sentences helter skelter comes AG talk
to Manson in prison in 1989 a bunch of
children was given their lives for what
they believed in it was an episode with
lots of different reasons Susie had one
reason unless they had another you know
what Leslie told the court he said he
said what did you think when you were
stabbing that woman said to at least you
won't be sending your sons in Vietnam